Let's get started by asking
Sergey Brin the co-founder of Google
what the most important thing
is in building a search engine.
>> So let's get a take how to decision.
We've been here before right.
>> I think the most important thing if
you're going to build a search engine
is to have really good fun
corpus to start out with.
In our case, we use the world wide web,
which at the time was significantly
smaller than it was today.
But it was also very new and exciting,
there were all sorts of
unexpected things there.
There are lots of other really
interesting corpuses of information.
And, of course, we've worked on one for
books and one for
people's, for your email, individually.
There are many, many interesting
corpuses out there and I think you
should pick the right one that you will
be excited about searching yourself.